welcome back to the second panel of the
day I'm gonna introduce the panel and
try to keep everything going on time and
then ideally there'll be lots of time
for questions let me introduce the first
speaker Cecile
Audrey she's a professor of French
literature and culture at Stanford and
also a research fellow at sails PO in
Paris she's a specialist of political
rhetoric and especially the discourse of
the far right she's her last book was
published in 2017 in french and
addressed the discourses of the main
candidates in the 2017 french french
president presidential election which
just took place in May and she is also
the author of Mahinda been taken to her
words deciphering the new national
French discourse out from soy in 2015
thank you thank you so if like me you
compared the French and American
political landscapes just about a year
ago and we're trying to see where the
wind was blowing I hope you didn't bet
any money in September 2016 there were
concerns in France about the very good
polling numbers of far-right candidate
Mahela Pen in fact for a straight year
she had been leading the polls for the
2017 presidential race and momentum was
on her side by contrast that's her curve
polling numbers by contrast here the
odds seem to be stacked against Trump or
so we were told of course the rest is
history
in France Emmanuel macron a culturally
brought pro-europe centrist won in a
landslide against Mahela ban with 65% of
the votes
thereafter the National Front spiral
down and crashed at a miserable 13% of
the votes in the following congressional
elections in June lending exactly what
it was five years before you know what
happened here in 2016 and 17
Plus August's so it would be comforting
to declare the French far-right obsolete
and harmless at least in comparison to
the American all rights reserved but
doing so we would risk repeating the
same mistakes that left many of us off
guards on November 8 2016 we would risk
suffering five years from now what new
elections happen in France from the same
lack of vigilance that that led in part
to Trump's victory sure there was a sigh
of relief when Mahima been failed to get
to get even close to the presidency in
France but we should not confuse
electoral setbacks and cultural
information short-term indicators such
as elections and long-term ideological
trends nor she would mistake the
cleaned-up palatable discourse that
Marylebone has refurbished her party
with was the party's core ideology and
it's continuous affiliation with the
galaxy of radical networks that
sustained her and will be waiting for
the payback when the time comes what I
want to examine today is the state of
the cultural war in France between the
radical right in and around National
Front and on the other hand the
Democratic humanist anti-racist camp I
take Martin attends party and its
evolution as a symptom as much as a
catalyst of recent trends in public
opinion and by examining its official
message its underlying ideology but also
the outside networks and actors that
foster its success I hope to paint a
more accurate picture of the ecology of
xenophobia in France and to assess its
to action or decline I'm first going to
look at the front national front itself
and then after my attention to some of
the political and cultural actors that
participate to its normalization so
first Kanu is the new National Front
here I want to put into question two
reassuring narratives that I think mask
the entrenchment of racist prejudices in
large segments of French society the
first narratives is that the National
Francois
has been stopped in its tracks in the
2017 electoral cycle the second one is
that of a did ya bellezza soon or
detoxification of the party since Matty
Levin took over from her father in 2011
let's first dispel the first fallacy of
a weak National Front defeat is not the
same as decline the 2017 electoral
results were disappointing only compared
to opinion polls that precede it is but
preceded them but solely not compared to
the history of the party at large this
graph tells anything but the story of a
decline between 2002 the last time that
the National Front got to the second
round of the presidential election in
2017 the far-right party has doubled its
political weight gaining 5 million
voters out of 47 million voters across
the board and 16 percentage points
between the first and the second round
of this election cycle Mahela Payne was
first at 7 million and get 3 million
additional voters in the second round in
spite of record low turnout and of calls
by every other party to vote against her
by contrast so we have the comparison
here jean-marie Le Pen barely improved
his score by less than a percentage
point in 2002 in the face of so the
question was we have acknowledged this
remarkable winning streak is to
understand what it means to vote Mahan
lepen today as opposed to jean-marie Le
Pen yesterday and this is where the
second reassuring narrative comes in
that of a new National Front which would
not be that toxic or racist anymore and
I'm going to start with an anecdote that
speaks to the perception that father and
daughter are two different beasts in
April 2015
days after a historic victory of the
national Fontaine local elections
jean-marie Le Pen found nothing better
to do than to reiterate his 1987
statement that the Holocaust was I quote
a detail in the history of world war two
a week later he went on to extol the
she regime in the anti-semitic weekly
viva hall where he also expressed his
sympathy for those who fight against
democracy denounced the gay lobby and
lamented the demise of the white world
needless to say they didn't go too well
with public opinion but what was
surprising is that it was a storm within
the national font her father's adverse
was flying in the face of marine lepen
sufficient work of did yoga resume the
Japanese as soon an effort to rebrand
the National Front as mainstream and
just a few months before the
presidential race was going to start she
couldn't take the risk of having her
father's old style outbursts flying into
her face and being obstacle to arise so
Joe Mahela pen was officially suspended
and then kicked out from the party that
he himself had found had founded in 1972
not only that but this political
parasite was staged and broadcast live
on prime-time television for maximum
political dividends days after the Reba
Hall interview Mahoney Pence and her
father political death warrant of TF
font Newshour what has gone unnoticed in
this political assassination is that to
condemn her father she invoked a set of
arguments that are entirely foreign to
the national thought all style to
justify her rather overdue condemnation
of her father's racial views she quoted
what she called the political line of
the party I quote the National Front
contributes to the expression of
suffrage within the framework defined by
the Republic and within democratic
pluralism it is attached to equality
before the law of every French citizen
regardless of origin race or religion on
TV it looked like Martina Penn was
siding with Universalist and republican
values against her father's racialist
politics but was she using a rhetoric of
humanism or issuing a genuine
humanistic statements the arch watcher
answer this question is methodologically
as possible by calming over five hundred
five hundred texts 1.5 million words of
both father and and daughter and the
result of this weather ruse and labor
was that from a lexical point of view it
is true that there is a marked
difference between father and daughter
it is a fact that machina pen has
entirely crossed out from her speech the
most retrograde visibly discriminatory
lexical markers of the far-right
anti-semitism misogyny and biological
racism or out not once that she used the
words black or Arab and when she uses
Jewish it is condemned to condemn the
Allah cost in the most an ambiguous
manner or to defend I quote our Jewish
fellow citizens and quote against the
alleged anti-semitism of the volume in a
remarkable 180-degree turn compared to
her God invoking pro-life father she has
positioned herself at the champion of
light city or secularism and of
minorities or at least some minorities
however a closer analysis shows that
this lexical makeover is deceptive and
might be even more dangerous or
pernicious than Jamaa Hill opens outward
racism she abides by the letter while
violating the spirit of the universal
values pretends to a halt in quasi
Orwellian fashion Mahela pen manages to
make words mean the opposites of the
weather were truly intended to convey so
for instance with incredible aplomb the
champion of national preference praised
cultural diversity in September 2016 the
world will survive only through human
cultural and biological diversity she
said and she added to a lot of people
surprised yes to multiculturalism but
the end of her sentence dispelled any
doubt about her true opinions regarding
a melting pot society yes true
multiculturalism
the planet no too much secure tourism
within a single country so defending
cultural diversity in her mouth means
excluding it entirely for the boundaries
of the uniform Christian world a
Christian nation and while some
signifiers are emptied out of their
original meaning others stretched to new
levels of semantic elasticity in
particular the words culture and
identity have become the new politically
correct synonyms for race but surprising
the word race from one's vocabulary is
not the same as renouncing a race-based
ideology xenophobia and a biological
definition of citizenship remain the
algeri called core of the national cross
platform today like before the party
proposes to abolish entirely the use
Solis the right to become a citizen of a
country you were born in in favor of use
sanguinis only that is citizenship by
blood and lineage and it would restrict
naturalizations and immigration to
almost zero in a clear effort to
preserve the purity of the French nation
so we can to me a moment to think about
what does this racism without the word
race means in terms of the state of the
culture war in France if we read Martin
Lapine's newly found leftists pedigree
in light of a much broader long-term
battle between anti-racist and racist
agenda her adoption of a secular
feminists and human rights lexicon
speaks to the cultural hegemony in
France of ethical and political norms
that were once the prerogative of the
new left and on the one hand it's
probably good news that the silent
revolution described by hingle heart has
transformed the National Front itself
it's a good measure of democracy's
robustness that even the far-right knows
that it would be political suicide to
run an anti-semitic and racist agenda
but on the other hand hiding a hate
based race-based platform under the thin
veil of the Universalist lexicon might
SAP even more dangerously the foundation
French democracy when public opinion
perceived the national transduce
coursers normal because it cannot be
singled out as easily at the deviations
of the political norm
the risk is that xenophobia itself
becomes mainstream and I'm going to turn
to the broader cultural context where
her discourse has been normalized by the
app from the outside in the last 10 to
15 years the political discourse at
large has drifted to the right
dramatically - just to this just a few
political actors who have adopted the
national sponsors axioms we have on the
right former Minister Netanyahu who
spoke of France as a white waste country
and on the left then Prime Minister
Manuel Valls stigmatized the Roma
population as being prone to stealing
impossible to integrate and entirely
unwelcome about Muslims he said I quote
I wished we could demonstrate that Islam
is compatible with the Republic and
quotes implying therefore that it was
not yet the case in 2016 far left
presidential candidate jean-luc
mélenchon stigmatized East European
detached workers as I could
stealing the bread of French people this
new rhetoric saturated with a profound
animosity for foreigners in general and
Islam in particular is reinforced by a
galaxy of radical right influencers and
the paradox here is that at the same
time that the National Front has
internalized the lexical taboos that
Jonah Hill Upen so gleefully Transwest
actors outside of the party have
embarked explicitly on a cultural war to
promote a nativist agenda and first
among these actors are is it exam or
whom I will take as a case study as mo
has made a name for himself at the very
luxury of career as a polemicist
he's adopting the exact opposite
rhetorical strategy as Martin Levin
where she has sugar-coated her most
questionable folk positions he professes
to being the true Stella
business and in a kind of reinforced
even ins Breitbart news but the
difference between with bread partners
as that Zim who has been precasting his
arguments on primetime television and in
mainstream media at one point he could
commands weekly you know in the same
week on a radio channel in the morning
on two talk shows in the evening in the
magazine Figaro magazine and he had his
own talk show on Saturday at primetime
hour and his bestseller French suicide
sold 500,000 copies in 2014 the argument
of the book it's that the visa regime
should be praised for having supposedly
saved French Jews and that France is
doomed because of the emasculation of
the watt European male if exam mr.
trottie matter matters because of the
content medium and semantics of his
discourse in the rising ecology of hate
that I am describing he fulfills a
unique role as interpreter influencer
and prescriber of radical political
opinions to amass mass audience in terms
of contents he offers a simple Clash of
Civilizations narrative to which to read
the world in his last book became a poem
end it for nothing chronicles of the
Warsaw positions he agrees that France
and Europe have entered a civil war
between its judeo-christian native
population and its Muslim population
immigrants this interpretive grade
prepares the public for the most drastic
of measures once the right political
leader comes into play in a 2014
interview zimmo envisage in earnest
deporting five million French Muslims to
avoid a civil war but even before these
acculturation of prejudices can bear
fruits in the long run it also serves
key functions in the ecology of the
far-right
on the one hand the Muslim statement
make marine lepen look moderate and
center by contrast instead of far-right
and extreme on the other hand
hammers home only more crudely the very
subtext of her ideological word view and
he does so illegitimate media platforms
that broadcast to the mass public
another role of zimo is that of
interpreter not of history but of marine
lepen is quoted lingua he states in
simpler more candid terms Mahina that as
euphemisms for instance when he when she
urges to fight I quote crime real crime
the one that has been prospering for so
many years in our value or when she
stigmatized this youth that are at war
with friends without naming exactly who
she has in mind
Zemo translates bluntly it's normal that
French from immigrant rules we control
more often by the police because most
drug dealers are blacks or Arabs that's
a fact
end quote then was more explicit style
is particularly helpful to impact my
hennepin cementing reworking of the
words
islam and immigration when he explains i
quote there is no difference between
Islam and Islamism french islam is an
oxymoron because islam means submission
and the word french comes from frank
which means pre the next thirty years
about to bring either civil war or
submission he gives us the key to decode
Mahela pens more elliptical allusions
for instance when she praised i quote
those who fight those who die in the
camping of terror that is intended to
precede submissions equipped with
Zimmer's etymologies we can understand
better why marine lepen is so intent and
is criticizing Islam isms in general
once she actually mean Islam to conclude
in France is radical right ecosystem the
National phones new political leaders
have adopted Frances current discursive
and legal norms to gain legitimacy in
the ballot box while other players who
can expect a financial and authority
boost from polemics and hyperbole take
care of the other part of the job the
indoctrination of the minds in other
words not only the National phone at a
record high
votes not only is it not a cleaned-up
humanist party in spite of what it
pretends to be not only do new voters
come to it for the same clan of Hobbit
reasons that the old voters but it
exists in fabric agenda is even more
widespread than one would think
the National Front at 35 percent might
be just the tip of the iceberg thank you
and our last speaker of this panel today
is Marcus Poole who is a historian and
the graduate program director and
research associate at the center through
anti-semitism abortion at the Technische
universität berlin and he's been in that
position since 2011 and from 2006 to
2010 he was the da-ad visiting professor
at York University in Toronto he is a
historian of the political writing of
conservative elites in Germany since in
the modern period since 1800 and is
currently working on a book length essay
on the historical foundations of
multiculturalism in Germany
thank you very much took place in order
first you so we are entering the stage
of the this conference where it's
getting increasingly difficult to say
something absolutely new but I'm trying
to by presenting a case that in many
regards seems to be exceptional I will
talk about Germany and the formation of
a new right and the conditions of this
formation of a new right Germany is an
exceptional case because it is the land
where the Nazis actually had been in
power terrorizing any political
opposition discriminating
all sorts of people that were not
perceived part of the Forex Gemeinschaft
unleashing the Second World War and
finally planning and executing the
murder of European Jews but it is also
an exceptional case because despite all
shortcomings and setbacks at least or at
the latest since the mid-1980s this
country has taken up responsibility for
the nafs for its national socialist part
to such an extent that anti-nazi Essen
and anti anti-semitism have become
cornerstones of the political culture
this is for example reflected in a very
dynamic and all-encompassing memory
culture in any one of you who might have
been to Berlin yet and have kind of seen
the presence of the memorial landscape
in the the city will have an impression
of of that also Germany has implemented
quite strict laws against Holocaust
denial and against I mean almost well
against forms of anti-semitism related
to Nazis and even to the free speech is
limited in that regard
it also has implemented laws that well
practically ban the use of Nazi symbols
and Nazi language in the
public space secondly the well neo-nazis
so I mean well in the the stricter sense
of the term have been quite successfully
marginalized and put to the fringes of
society a new right so-called new right
has emerged and it's trying to get entry
into the kind of political discourse and
the political system through a party
that was found in only a few years ago
the identity of a few doors down the
alternative for Germany but still I mean
we have an upcoming election a federal
election in two weeks and I mean I know
we should rely on polls anymore but it
can be expected for quite sure the 90%
of the votes will go to political party
to we'll go to democratic political
parties and not to the new right-wing
party so believe it or not Germany has
over the well last year's established
one of the most stable political systems
in the Western world even at the cost
that we're having one woman ruler for 12
years now and most likely almost sure
for another four years third and I think
this is a very important point it has
been mentioned yesterday to a Germany
has a functioning Democratic
Conservative Party that sticks to the
fundaments of you indecency as well as
to the idea
to the values of a pluralistic society
and I mean in all countries where
right-wing movements have kind of
entered the governmental sphere they had
kind of cooperated with deteriorating
conservative parties and I mean this is
all credits to angle America in that
case the Conservative Party in Germany
has drawn a strict clear red line not to
get into any talks and coalition's with
party that sits right from them and
fourth there was a deep knowledge at
least in the western part of Germany
that Germany is one of those countries
that has been benefiting most from these
long term processes of
internationalization and Europeanization
I mean this was kind of the entry a
ticket back to the international world
after world war ii have integrating into
international a structure in particular
the what then became the European Union
and finally over the years at least
since the 1960s Germany has developed a
very strong critical civil society and
that includes a critical media
ironically I've spoken to many
colleagues from other countries under
stress ironically Germany has become to
some outside observers a sort of a last
resort or a hope of the
of the liberal West and who would have
thought maybe not well not only after 45
but a generation ago that we would end
up in such a situation so I would say
Germany is an example for the
possibility of historical learning and
profound change in and sustainable
change in political culture however
though to be sure there exists as I mean
the paper that had been read out there
exists kind of every day as well as
institutionalized racism and also
widespread anti-muslim resentment among
the German population there exists
solids anti-semitic resentments of solid
unstable anti-semitic resentments across
society there are frequent outbreaks of
xenophobic violence attacks and refugee
shelters or maybe you have heard about
that there existed the this murderous
so-called National Socialist underground
a terrorist a Nazi a terrorist group
that murdered eleven Germans with
migrant a background over a time span of
about ten years and there is widespread
hate speech particularly in social media
as I mean this is a general phenomena as
in other parts of the Western world but
this talk is not about these activities
this talk is about the new right so the
self fashioned new right and its
strategic as well as ideological
reorientation understood by them as a
prerequisite to enter
German mainstream discourse first
because it is virtually banned from this
discourse secondly I will briefly
discuss than the inconsistencies and
contradictions of these positions and
how they are actually connected to
historical National Socialism and then I
will use for short case studies if I
have time but I try to do so to
demonstrate how this focused thought of
the new right has entered the
alternative of Deutschland and to what
extent this party has become a political
arm of the extra-parliamentary
new right after world war ii in the
shadow of the activities of former Nazis
and then neo-nazi neo-nazis intellectual
of intellectuals of the far-right
started to reorient themselves so they
set themselves apart from these neo-nazi
activities the most important person in
that early period beginning in the 1950s
was actually a Swiss born historian
named Abbey moolah he was actually the
private secretary of Anne's Duma a
famous author of a kind of heroic author
that sort of glorified the war
experience in World War one worked and
well into National Socialism and fared
well actually under the Nazis he
published a book in the 1950s entitled
the conservative revolution when he
tried to homogenize anti-liberal and
anti-democratic authors of the interwar
period and separated separating them
from Nancy
geology he tried to reintroduce these
authors into the Canon of a conservative
thought and among these authors are
ossified Spangler the author of the
decline of the West in taganga zabun
Landis in German the car Schmitz the
notorious lawyer and well lawyer of the
fueler actually and supporter of the
Nazis until the mid-1930s at vanilla
fondant Forman book who created the turn
third right or Edgar you use Jung who
published a book in the 1920s entitled
the rule of the inferior an attack
against the Verma Republic
so these pre Nazi authors are the most
and still are no the most eminent
historical reference reference points of
the new rights political thought how
does the I mean this is part of the most
important question how does the
so-called new right distance itself from
maths ISM first of all most importantly
they turned away from anti-semitism and
biological racism as kind of core of
their ideology instead they are
promoting so-called as no pluralism
saying that there are races there are
but these races are not
in equal they are kind of equally worth
but they need to be separated so it's an
ideology of segregation secondly
certainly in this and this camouflage
the ideology of inequality that's that's
behind that's behind it then secondly
where's mark this refers to his dog they
reject kind of bald Holocaust denial and
distortion instead they focus on
attacking forms of established forms of
Holocaust Remembrance so just to to kind
of catch works I will talk about them in
a couple of minutes like so the idea
that Holocaust Remembrance has become a
show up business from which Jews all
over the globe are profiting from or the
accusation that Germany has adopted
Holocaust Remembrance as a new Civic
religion replacing other forms of
religious belief then another important
point that refers to actually Manuela
talk from yesterday they had have
adopted the concept of meta politics
with reference to ever lab but also to
Graham she they are trying to slowly
winning over cultural or first access to
a public discourse and then winning
cultural had cultural hegemony so they
are sitting back they're not kind of in
action as you might think in regard to
to to to Nazis but sitting back waiting
trying to influence
public discourse in a long-term
perspective that goes along with a
general in an intellectualization
of the movement including the rereading
Dean AXA fiying and reinterpretation of
seminal works from German idealism
political romanticism to the
above-mentioned anti-liberal authors
also they're looking abroad I mean some
of the names have been have been have
been mentioned one I was missing act or
two there I was missing the French
author Randall Camus who created the
term Lagrangian plus small the great
exchange so the idea that European white
population is kind of purposely replaced
by what non-white minorities and very
important book another name is Russian
well I don't want to say intellectual
Russian thinker Alexandre Dugan who has
kind of renewed this ideology or idea of
a Eurasia Eurasian empire that would sit
against the United States of America or
the West as an idea so this new right in
Germany is actually referring to both of
these authors among others then as I had
indicated rather than being kind of
political activists they try to inform
political circles it's kind of a very
elitist concept there's also something
to do because they don't have any mass
basis yeah they they don't have brown
shirts on the streets of they're trying
to influence
small intellectual circles that work
then into a broader a broader public and
again the bimah republic serves as a
model there where such clubs already
existed including I've heard of these
then I would say most interesting
there are adopting strategies from the
left we've seen some of the images well
when we think of neo-nazis we have a
certain image in mind these guys don't
look data they are not brown sure that
they they wave flags but they don't wave
swastikas what they're forbidden in
Germany as I said they use they look for
other symbols yesterday in a
conversation I mentioned that the
Confederate flag actually is being used
quite widely but other flags as well but
if you look at their well at they're
kind of members I mean they look like
who are quite young
they look like I mean have adopted
hipster culture they come with Euler and
ease and so it's not that kind of
violent appearance anymore but rather
casual appearance and I think that's a
quite important change in in in
appearance we also have to keep in mind
so I'm speaking of the ID so called
identitarian movement that is very
active and then as a last important
point they are trying to
institutionalize right-wing thought by
establishing professional networks
serious magazines
fishing houses and even the think tanks
so in Berlin there was a so-called
library of conservatism I won't speak
much about that but very interesting
place to go and in the some provincial
place in eastern show me
Gert's kubacheck had founded as a one of
the actress that seen the so called
National Policy Institute that is
compromised with a with a publishing
house where he tries to network connect
bring people from abroad from Germany
from the political from the alternative
for Germany together with intellectuals
of the so-called new right and actually
this is where the where the title of my
talk is coming from the widening of the
thin line because in quite influential
essay kubacheck stated that the new
right in germany is walking on a very
thin line and there they need to work
into the public discourse they need to
adopt a long term strategy in order to
widen the possibilities so far I think I
have to skip little bit there is there
is much hope that this movement is a
stain kind of marginalized first of all
because they don't really don't have a
mass basis there is no charismatic
leader inside which i think is quite
important for these
there is a strong opposition coming from
civil society and more important I think
is the utter rejection of this movement
by the democratic parties including the
Conservatives this just as a last remark
I just read today and actually
conservative German newspaper that the
Ministry of Justice which is led by a
Social Democrat together with the
Ministry of the Interior which is led by
a pursuit if are preparing a lawsuit -
they want to bring it to the
Constitutional Court to ban the dog said
after the election because of some
anti-democratic and openly racist
remarks some of their members had made
in the in the last week so there is
strong
there is a strong with rejection from
civil society as well as from the
political elites in Germany thank you
very much
[Music]